dieser Typ wollte 5000 € Schadensersatz
von mir weil ich ihn damals manchmal
meine Youtube Videos mit eingebunden
habe und ich bin mir sicher ihr kennt
den alle 2019 ist bei mir ein
Anwaltsschreiben reingeflattert und
darin hieß es ich soll erstmal
unterlassen weiterhin diesen Clip zu
verwenden und ihm aufgrund von
verschiedener privater Dinge die ich
jetzt hier nicht preisgeben möchte 5000
€ Schadensersatz zahlen soll ich habe
mir dann natürlich auch einen Anwalt
genommen und am Ende musste ich nur
meine Anwaltskosten tragen das ging also
nicht durch und es handelt sich um den
Typen der auch heute immer noch in
vielen Youtube Videos zu sehen ist und
zwar sagt er so in unserem ProSieben
oder Sat.1 Interview hä ja das habe ich
mir damals auch gedacht